[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau vip
aujourd'hui nous sommes à la
bibliothèque universitaire de saint
quentin en yvelines avec léon dubois un
photographe indépendant bonjour alors
vous exposer ici 17 photos qui ont été
prises lors d'un grand voyage c'était
pas un voyage au hasard pourquoi avoir
fait ce voyage
alors j'ai suivi en fait l'itinéraire de
jean cocteau qui a publié en 1949 un
journal de bord de son voyage en
méditerranée
c'est un voyage qui a duré trois mois et
donc j'ai géré fait une interprétation
photographique de son de son voyage il
est parti donc en mars 1949 de paris il
a traversé l'egypte le liban la turquie
et puis la grèce et il faisait donc une
série de représentations théâtrales il
projetait aussi certains de ses films il
était accompagné d'une troupe de théâtre
voilà et en lisant maalesh donc soixante
dix ans plus tard et bien je sentis ce
livre d'une actualité est très
intéressante et je vois là je proposais
de faire donc une interprétation
photographique contemporaine de cet
ouvrage
et qu'est-ce qui a fait que vous avez
choisi ce livre alors en fait il ya un
moment très particulier c'est
donc j'étais à alexandrie ce que je suis
basée à alexandrie en egypte et je
lisais m'allège de jean cocteau et il
parle dans le livre il explique un
passage de son voyage aux îles et sur la
corniche d'alexandrie sur le front de
mer dans un hôtel c'est l'hiver il ya
une tempête terrible à l'extérieur et
puis en fait dans cet hôtel là aucune
des portes et des fenêtres ne ferment
parce que voilà il ya une telle tempête
que le vent ouvre ouvre tout est donc en
fait au moment où je lisais cet extrait
j'étais moi-même dans un hôtel sur la
corniche d'alexandrie et abusant
exactement la même situation puisqu'il y
avait en fait une tempête et j'ai mon
ami qui était en train de clouer les
fenêtres et les portes de 7 de son hôtel
pour que ça ne ne s'ouvre pas et donc je
me suis dit voilà cet ouvrage à 70 ans
et pourtant il est très actuel il ya une
forme de bad d'intemporalité dedans il
ya quelque chose qui se rêve secret
c'est là où je me suis dit ok on peut on
peut peut-être essayer d'aller chercher
les traces de jean cocteau en
méditerranée et donc sur ces photos
aujourd'hui on voit quoi alors ça a été
un peu le challenge c'est à dire que ce
projet s'est fait en deux temps il ya eu
déjà un travail un gros travail de
recherches en archives pour retrouver
exactement les lieux où était passée
jean cocteau donc aller dans les
archives retrouvé le manuscrit retrouvé
un peu comprendre comment s'est
construit cet ouvrage voilà ou de quelle
manière je coupe tout prenez ces notes
est ce que c'était vraiment déjà très
structuré ce que c'était prix sur des
bouts de cartes postales sur l'écrit un
peu sur les genoux voilà je voulais voir
ça et donc il ce travail de recherche
pour retrouver aussi les lieux
exactement où est ce qu'il est passé et
ensuite une fois que j'ai effectué le
voyage
je ne savais pas si j'allais retrouver
exactement les lieux décrits par cocteau
dans toutes ces villes où il est passé
ou alors voilà est-ce que j'allais
trouver les lieux changent et 70 ans
plus tard c'est un peu la question est
finalement donc ça c'est bien accordé
puisque j'ai
je suis retourné sur ces lieux là est
évidemment 70 ans plus tard tout avait
changé
donc il ya certains lieux que je n'ai
pas retrouvé quand il parle de
typiquement d'istanbul qui est parsemé
du sinn avec une ambiance très spéciale
pleine de fumée ça y avait plus du tout
donc c'est vraiment des lieux qui ont
changé et donc c'est là où j'ai dû avoir
une deuxième lecture de l ouvrage en
dépassant le côté descriptif des villes
qu'ils visitent et en m'attachant plutôt
au côté intemporel de la manière dont il
les décrit en fait la manière dont ils
regardent les villes il ya un côté très
poétique qu'il a et intemporel où il va
parler des lumières des ambiances et des
atmosphères de ces villes là et c'est
exactement ce que j'ai aussi senti en
2020 quand j'ai fait les photos c'est ça
aussi moi mon regard est plus axé sur
les lumières les ambiances et donc les
deux ensuite ça a permis de créer un une
exposition un travail photographique où
le texte de jean cocteau dialogue avec
les images que j'ai pu que j'ai pu créer
et alors cette expression est resté
jusqu'au 12 février ensuite elle repart
en egypte avec vous qu'est ce qui fait
que son parcours
donc elle voyage l'idée c'est de la
faire aussi voyager sur les traces de
cocteau donc elle va être exposé
l'institut français d'alexandrie en
égypte au festival international de
photo du caire et puis aussi en france
voilà ça va notamment à léo au musée
jean cocteau de menton dans le sud est
voilà l'idée c'est de retrouver aussi
que ce dialogue entre le texte de
cocteau et mes photographies puissent
voyager sur les lieux de jean cocteau et
donc alexandrie c'est là où vous vous
êtes basé qu'est ce qui vous plaît dans
cette ville c'est une vie qui
m'intéresse beaucoup par son côté là
aussi intemporel c'est à dire que c'est
une ville avec une très longue histoire
il ya beaucoup cette ville qui a été
fondée par donc alexandre le grand
beaucoup communauté étrangère très forte
beaucoup de beaucoup de grecs et
italiens d'arméniens de france est aussi
et d'égyptiens bien sûr et c'est une
ville qui a une identité très
spécifiques dans les années 50 la
majorité des étrangers sont partis et
c'est une ville qui s'est complètement
réinventé qu'il ya qui a changé et voilà
c'est il ya une forme de rapport à la
mémoire qui est très particulier à une
architecture aussi très particulière il
me ferait identité alexandrine qui
m'intéresse est alors pour avoir voyagé
un petit peu dans ces pays dont jean
cocteau parle
quel regard porter aujourd'hui sur ces
villes par rapport au regard que peut
porter jean cocteau à cette époque là
bas c'était justement en fait l'idée de
ce que je vais retrouver exactement ce
que cocteau des cris ou non et
et donc en effet quand je suis retourné
sur sur les lieux devant cocteau n'y
avait pas tout avait changé et c'est là
où j'ai dû avoir une deuxième lecture du
livre qui est plus ne pas prendre ce
livre maalej comme un témoignage
historique mais plus comme un objet
poétique et littéraire et c'est ça que
j'avais retrouvé et qui a permis de qui
m'a permis de faire un lien avec mes
photographies en fait il ya quelque
chose qui se crée c'est à dire que j'ai
pris j'ai sélectionné dans maalej des
extraits qui ont une forme
d'intemporalité parce qu'il parle des
lumières des ambiances etc
et ça ça n'a pas changé donc la forme
des villes change mais leur âme reste
est moins des photographies sont des
photographies qui sont prises en
argentique en noir et blanc et donc il
ya aussi finalement un côté intemporel
en fait au début quand j'ai montré
l'exposition il ya certaines personnes
qui m'ont dit abete
c'est fou on croirait que ce sont les
photographies ont été prises par cocteau
qui date de l'époque alors que pas du
tout selon des photographies
contemporaines aux clients essaient de
brouiller aussi un peu les pistes de
prendre de prendre des extraits qui
aurait pu être écrit aujourd'hui mais
qui ont été créés il ya 70 ans et des
photographies qui ont été prises
aujourd'hui mais qui aurait pu avoir
lieu il ya 70 ans et donc de dit de
poser la question de aussi de l'identité
méditerranéenne donc voilà on il ya
soixante dix ans d'écart entre ce texte
et cette image et donc s'interroge
qu'est-ce qui subsistent qu'est ce qui a
disparu et un peu voilà l'identité
méditerranéenne qu'est ce que c'est
réellement fier qu est-ce qui traverse
ces différents pays mais aussi qu est-ce
qui traverse à différentes époques et
donc avant ce grand voyage vous êtes
allé à calais dans ce qu'on appelle la
jungle donc c'est un camp de migrants de
réfugiés qui vivent dans d'extrême
conditions pourquoi vous êtes allé là
bas alors c'était donc en 2015 j'étais
en master 2 recherche en histoire
culturelle et sociale ici à l'université
de versailles
et donc c'est une formation qui est
spécialisée notamment sur la
compréhension des pratiques
journalistiques en histoire des médias
et je me suis donc j'entendais
quotidiennement à la radio parlée de la
jungle de calais ce qui s'y passait oui
je n'arrivais pas à trouver une
en fait un reportage ou un travail qui
permettent de comprendre ce lieu-là dans
sa globalité donc qui sont les personnes
qui sont là bas comment elles vivent etc
et l'idée m'est venue je faisais déjà de
la photographie en argentique aussi et
je me suis dit bah tiens ça peut être
intéressant d'aller sur place et d'aller
documenté cet espace est d'aller tout
simplement pour quelqu'un qui ne connaît
pas le contexte qui ne connaît pas ce
qui se passe là bas est allé expliquer
un plot mama et donc je suis parti
pendant six mois j'ai documenté sur sur
le long terme donc à la fois le comment
vivent les gens et puis aussi les ong
qui pouvaient travailler sur place et
l'idée c'était donc de proposer vraiment
un reportage sur le temps nom de cet
espace là et de comprendre comment
est-ce qu'ils s'organisent et puis les
détails de la vie quotidienne ses rides
et aussi d'aller à un peu à contre
courant des pratiques de l'actualité où
je voyais beaucoup de journalistes passé
qui était finalement qui passe et voilà
une demi journée mais qui n'allait pas
forcément rester dans le temps long et
moi l'idée c'était vraiment de pouvoir
raconter aussi l'histoire des gens et de
prendre le temps voilà c'est quelque
chose qui est difficile
si elle est contrainte de l'information
bien sûr mais voilà c'était l'idée de
pouvoir proposer quelque chose un peu de
la qui puisse s'étaler sur plusieurs
mois et ses fauteuils jamais été exposés
quelque part oui elles ont été exposées
ici à l'université
et puis ensuite ça a été publié
également voilà dans plusieurs plusieurs
médias au luxembourg notamment
intéressés par ce sujet en fait ce qui a
intéressé c'est le fait que je puisse
documenté en argentique et en noir et
blanc un fait d'actualité et donc en
fait en utilisant une technique qui est
complètement en décalage avec le rythme
de l'actualité qui est
voilà qui était très
très rapide quoi de vraiment de en fait
le fait que la technique utilisée soit
en décalage avec la le rythme de la
médiatisation et donc nous vous avez
rencontré d'abord en 2012 à ce moment là
vous aviez 17 ans et vous aviez organisé
une exposition sur la première guerre
mondiale
elle risque avant la passion de la
photographie c'est avant tout la passion
de l'histoire
oui alors il ya c'est vrai que j'avais
commencé à une exposition sur la j'avais
fait plusieurs expositions sur la
première guerre mondiale ce qui
m'intéressait dans ce sujet c'était le
rapport à la mémoire qu'on retrouve dans
mes photographies en fait parce que
l'idée c'est ce que je vous disais pour
maalesh c'était l'idée de poser la
question de l'identité méditerranéenne
et finalement ça rejoint ce rapport à la
mémoire donc je collectionnais les
objets de la première guerre mondiale en
me posant en posant cette cette question
qu'est ce que ces objets nous apprennent
de la guerre qu'est ce que ces objets
nous apprennent de la vie des personnes
en 1914 1918 et c'est donc en quoi ces
objets sont vecteurs d'une mémoire et
finalement ce travail sur jean cocteau
c'est aussi ça c'est à dire aller
chercher 70 ans plus tard les lieux de
jean cocteau c'est aller chercher la
mémoire aussi donc la mémoire de la
méditerranée qu'est-ce qui reste 70 ans
voilà donc il ya ce rapport en fait
toujours présent dans ce que je fais
voilà sur entre comment à la recherche
de la mémoire des mémoires et donc pour
transmettre la notamment maintenant vous
avez choisi la photo pourquoi ce support
du coup il permet aussi de faire
perdurer un peu la mémoire c'est ça
c'est à dire que là on est sur ce projet
spécifique de l'adaptation d'une oeuvre
littéraire
quand je fais une exposition l'idée
c'est évidemment de transmettre c'est à
dire que j'ai envie que le
visiteurs viennent et repartent en ayant
appris quelque chose ça passe par un
dispositif en deux temps le premier
c'est celui donc c'est comme le
processus que j'ai mis en place pour
créer cet objet photographique c'est à
dire une une base solide de recherche
donc vraiment faire une recherche sur
l'oeuvre comprendre comment est-ce
qu'elle a été construite
présenté lors de l'exposition visiteurs
le voyage de jean cocteau son parcours
en méditerrannée donc présenté voilà des
bases solides pour amener des éléments
de contexte et ensuite moi mon travail
de photographe c'est d'apporter une
sensibilité d'apporter une touche
personnelle un regard en fait sur sur
cet ouvrage notamment de cocteau donc
oui c'est l'objectif c'est de
transmettre bien sûr de transmettre une
mémoire qui passent ici voilà par un
double dispositif donc une explication
du contexte historique on va dire et
puis ensuite l'aspect plus artistique
qui est celui de l'interprétation
merci beaucoup léon dubois alors je
rappelle que ces photos elles seront
exposées à alexandrie dans quelques
semaines et puis ensuite au caire et
elles reviendront ici en france on
espère vous revoir pour votre prochain
travail qui est en cours si j'ai bien
compris
tout à fait oui merci beaucoup d'avoir
suivi cette émission et on se retrouve
bientôt dans un nouveau vie
[Musique]